so i'll now move on to markup
decisions processes or mdps
so i'll first introduce what mdps are
and then i'll define class
strategies and probabilities but mdp is
the man
so finally i'll talk about probabilistic
reachability for mdps
so i'll first consider qualitative
probabilistic slow reachability
so this is except reaching with it's
like
it's like probability greater than zero
or with probability one
and then i'll go into optimality looks
like equations
and finally how to actually compute
reachability probabilities for
mdps so first
what's the difference between mdps and
our dtmcs so in
mdps we also have non-determinism and
why do we need this well for some
aspects of
a system they might not be
probabilistic and therefore it doesn't
make sense for us to try to model them
probabilistically so some examples of
this is
our concurrency in the scheduling of
parallel
components so for example in some
randomized distributed
algorithms we have some multiple
probabilistic
processes that do have probabilistic
behavior
but then they operate a asynchronously
so so we don't know so the ordering that
they
move and it's like we want to consider
all
possible it's not interleaving so it
doesn't make sense to
model this it's not probabilistically
second we might
might have have a system in an unknown
environment for example this is some
probabilistic
slight security slap protocols where we
don't know how that
adversary are behaves so it's like we
want to model it
under all possible adversaries so it's
like we need to model
the choices that adversely makes
non-deterministic
a third so we might have select systems
which are which are under are specified
so
so we might not not know the precise
values for certain
model select parameters so
it's like we want to consider for
example a communication
sub protocol might say where
that the message that the protocol
should work where
the message propagation is like delays
are between
a upper or a lower up band so
here it's like we need to consider all
possible just like values so we make the
choice
of the delay as a non-deterministic
choice
select between the lower um between
values so between the lower and the
upper value and finally so
another example is if we abstract a
our dtmc for example by um
partitioning the states into um
similar but not identical states so then
we don't know
precisely what our state we're in so
it's like we know that there's
that um so so we don't know precisely
what the probabilistic
site behavior will be so we can have a
non-deterministic choice as to
what the actual probabilistic behavior
will will be
okay so we've got so
we have select models with just slight
probability and we have
some models with just non-determinism so
for example in a label
or transition site system or a crypt
structure then the choice is are
non-deterministic so we've got a set of
states
an initial state and then we've got a
transition our relation
where a pair is in the a relation if
there's a non-deterministic choice
if there is a select transition between
the two states
so for example in s1 here we've got
three possible
our transitions and the choice as to
which one is so
taken is non-deterministic on the other
hand in
so discrete time it's like markov chains
so again we've got a set of states
an initial state and here we've got a
probability transition
a matrix so here if we're in a state
there's a
the choice as to the successor state is
purely
it's like probabilistic if we take the
south loop with slight probability 0.01
we go to s3 with stock probability 0.98
and we go to s2 with some probability
0.01 and notice in
so both cases we also have a labeling
function that say assigns to states
that atomic propositions that hold
in that state or the properties of of
that state
so let's now introduce markov
certification
select processors which is which we can
consider as an
extension of dtmcs which allow
non-deterministic
choices so like
dtmcs and labeled transition systems we
have
a discrete set of states that represent
the
possible configurations of the system
being
modeled and we have that the transitions
select between states
that occur in discrete time steps
so what changes is that we have both
probabilistic and non-deterministic
behavior in each state so first there's
a non-deterministic choice between
the actions that are available in a
our state so one thing to note is that
different actions can be
it's not available in different states
of a
mdp and once an action is
chosen in a such state then that
successive state is chosen
probabilistically based on both the
action that is
chosen and the current state
so let's have a formal our definition so
like for our dtmcs we've got a finite
set of
it's like state supports the state space
we've got
an initial state and we've got a
labeling function
that assigns two states sets of
atomic um propositions and then
finally we have a partial transition
probability
it's that function so we've so we've got
a set of
actions a and dist s is the set so
discrete probability
distributions over the set s so we've
got
so given a state and a slight action
this might map to a um a distribution
since
it's a partial transition probability
it's like function
so in a state an action is said to be
available if p s of a
is uh are defined and
we denote by a of s the actions that are
so available in a state so that's the
set up
so actions for which the partial
transition probability
function is defined for the given
slight state so for example here we can
see
in state site zero only
the action a is so available as there's
only a
our transition labeled with the action a
while in state
s1 there's once um
there's two available select actions one
at b and if we choose b then we
move to state s zero with probability
point seven
while we remain in state s one with
probability point three
well if we choose action c in state s s1
then there's a 50 50 chance that we
moved
to state 2 or to state 3.
so let's consider another example so
this is a
modification of the simple it's like so
communication
protocol i modeled as a
dtmc in earlier it's like videos
so here we start in state s
zero then after one step we perform
action start and we start to try to send
a
our message so then in state one we have
a
it's like a non-terms a
non-deterministic choice
between so the actions send and wait so
we can choose to wait for example except
because the channel is
it's not busy or we can choose to send
try to send the
our message so first of all if we choose
to wait then we just stay in state
s r1 and we don't and nothing changes
or if we choose to send then with so
probability 0.99 we send
successfully and we move to state s at 3
and then we stop
which corresponds to corresponds to it's
like repeatedly
so performing the stop so action always
probability
point zero one we fail and then so we
move to
state s m two and then afterwards we
then
re in the next step we then perform
the reset so action and we start start
over from state
s0 so let's look at one other simple
example so here we've got four states so
from s
slot zero we have no choice the only
available action is a so we move to
s s slot one then in s1 we've got eight
non-deterministic choice
between two available actions b and c as
we've seen
if we choose action b then we either
return to zero with probability point
seven well there's a
self loop with probability point three
on the other hand if we choose action c
then there's a 50 50
random choice it's like between moving
to the state
s2 that corresponds to heads or s3 that
corresponds to two tails
so more so formally
this is a mdp where
the set of states is s0 s1 s2 and
s3 we've got the start state is s
0 in s 0 there's only one
available action which is a and that
corresponds to the
size distribution that picks s1 with
probability one
in state s1 there's two available so
actions b and c
for action b we um
this has probability the probability of
going to s 0 is 0.7 and s 1 is 0.3 well
if we choose c
then s 2 is chosen with probability 0.5
and
s s3 with probability 0.5 and then in
both s2 and
s3 there's only a is available
and and that is just causes a slight
self loop so
we choose s2 with probability one if
we're in s2
and we choose s3 with probability one if
we're in s3
and we also have the atomic propositions
which are init heads and
tails um zero is labeled with
init only s1 isn't labeled with so
anything
so a it returns the empty set
while s2 and s3 are labeled by heads and
tails
respectively so let's give one other
example to show how we can go from so if
we consider that asynchronous parallel
slight composition of two three-state
or dtmcs so in here if we're in
s so zero we move to s1 with
probability one if we're in s1 there's a
50 50 chance of
moving to s 0 or s 2 and if we're in s2
then we stay there with
some probability one and uh
so the second one is the same but the
states parts are labeled t0 t1
and t2 then we can build the
asynchronous parallel
of composition so in in each state
there's a
non-deterministic choice as to whether
this
dtmc moves or this one moves so
we're in state s zero t zero
either t this one moves and then
therefore so we move to the state where
s zero doesn't change and
we move to and t 0 changes to t 1 with
probability 1 or here this
our dtmc so it moves and we and s 0
changes from
s1 with probability 1 and t 0 obviously
does not change and you can work through
to see all the possible
states so note that i haven't included
the different actions i've just labeled
so the arrows with different it's like
colors
to correspond to the different action
it's like choices
so let's now go on to paths strategies
and probabilities for
mdps so first so
first a pass through an mdp is a
a sequence so it's a state and we
perform some
action and then we move to some slight
new state
and we're
it's like require that if we're in state
um so this should be s i so if we're in
state s i we choose
action ai then so we need to move to
state
s i plus one with probability greater
than zero
for all i so each of these transitions
happens with non-zero probability and
a path therefore
represents a possible execution or one
possible
a behavior of other system which the mdp
is
are modeling so we can define
path s as the set of all infinite paths
that start from some state s and we can
also
consider path pathfin of s as a set of
finite paths
that that start from some state s
now as we've seen paths
so as we can see paths that resolve
both the non-deterministic since it has
a
so action it says in s zero we choose
action
a so zero so we're resolving the
non-determinism
and we also set resolving it's like the
probabilistic
it's a choice as we say that after a
zero is so chosen we end up in state s1
so this resolves both the
non-deterministic and the probabilistic
sub-choices of the mdp
so how can we reason about the
probabilities
of a mdp so
what we need are
if we wanted to consider for example
what's the probability of some
event in an mdp so here we need what are
called
strategies okay so so we first
need to just resolve the
non-deterministic
choices but we need to keep the
probabilistic
choices and if we do this then by
resolving the non-deterministic choices
we end up with a
our dtmc and then as we've seen in
earlier our videos
we can define a probability measure
over the paths of this our dtmc
so as i said this can be done with a our
strategy
and this resolves only the
non-deterministic choice in an
mdp now strategies are also known as
either
such schedulers policies or adversaries
they're all they're all so equally
valid names for the same thing so
formally what
our strategy is is a function
that maps every finite path
to an available action of the last state
of that path so since
it chooses it based on the path then it
resolves the non-determinism based on
the execution
select history so given what has
happened
in the past what action should i select
the form next that's what a
strategy tells us to do
so let's consider the previous example
so notice in this mdp it's only in state
s1 where there's a a non-deterministic
choice so it's only in
in s1 where there's more than one slot
available
so action and here we have that we can
either choose
the action b or the action c so let's
first consider
that strategy sigma one that picks c are
the first time
so here after so here i have
uh it's like
omitted the actions from the paths just
to simplify the
our presentation so after after moving
from
s0 to s1 and this would correspond to
so performing it's like action a then
the strategy chooses
action c on the other hand we can
consider
the strategy sigma 2 the pics b the
first time
that we enter s1 but then there's a
chance
and then afterwards if we're in state
s1 it will always choose c so so the
first time so after it goes from s0 to
s1
next time it chooses b then after that
anytime it's in
s1 it will choose c
and that's just two some
examples of like the final of the finite
paths
it's like applying sigma one and sigma
two
so note that i just repeat that i
haven't
included certainly actions in the past
paths just to
keep things so simple in the
presentation
so given a a strategy then
we can define a set of paths path such
sigma s
so these are the paths from s where
so the non-determinism is resolved so
according to the strategy
sigma so now so these are the parts of
the form
where in the final step then
this action is the choice of
sigma after the path pi has been
are performed so for example if we
consider
the strategy sigma one that that picks c
for the first time in this case it's
like we go to a
and then so we pick c so we either go to
s two
or s3 so we either have the path that
goes from s1 to s
sorry from s0 to s1 to s2 and then just
does
this loop or we have the path that goes
from s0 to s1 to s3 and then we have
this
slight loop on the other hand if we
consider the strategy sigma 2 the first
that picks b for the first time and then
always pick c
then we're in s 0 and we either go to s
1 back to s 0
and then we go back to s1 and then we
either go to s2 or s3
so we go from s0 to s1 to s2 back to s1
and then to s2 or to s3
or when we go when we pick b
for the first time we get it's like the
self loop and then we pick c
and then we either go to s2 or s3 so
here we've got the path where we go
s0 s1 s1 s2 or s0
s1 s1 s3 and notice so again
i've omitted so the actions
from the path paths just to simplify the
presentation so given a
a starting state and a
strategy this actually so induces
a infinite state or dtmc
so it's a a dtmc that is based on it's
like the starting state
and the strategy sigma so how do we
i define this okay so we need to define
the states
initial state the probability transition
matrix and the labeling select function
so first
the states of this dtmc are the finite
paths of
the mdp that start in state s and
correspond to
it's like the adversary it's let's say
the initial state is just the very
simple path which is just
like the singleton's path s um
which is the path of length zero
and then what's the probability
transition
so matrix well if uh if we've got two
parts
pi and pi primed and pi primed is just
pi
followed by we perform so action a and
move to s prime and obviously it's like
we will require
that this is something action that sigma
select requires if it's like this is
true then it's just
like the probability that in
the final state of um pi
if we choose it's like action a
then we move to s prime so here s select
corresponds
this s should be sorry the last state of
um
pi as opposed to s
and if it's like this isn't true then we
set
select the probability to be it's like
equal to zero
and it's like the labeling that of the
path is just given by
x like the labeling of the last state of
the path
now it turns out that there's a one to
one correspondence step between the
paths
um of like the strategy
sigma um
starting from state s and the paths of
this are dtmc
so therefore this gives us a it's like
probability it's like measure
over the paths of sigma starting from
state s
by using so the probability
select measure for this it's like dtmc
that i introduced
in an earlier video
so let's finally give an example
so here this is a fragment of the
induced dtmc for
strategy sigma one so this is the one
that picks c
for it's like the first time so we've
got here notice that the states are
the finite paths and again i omitted
the actions from the path parts just to
simplify that
our presentation so here
when we're in s1 for the first time we
choose c
and therefore we move to either s2 or s3
with
probability 0.5 and then we just
afterwards just perform this loop over
and over
or this loop over and over again and
let's look at
a fragment of that for um it's like
sigma two
so here so the first time that we're in
s1 we choose action b
so we either return to s zero with
probability point seven or we stay in s1
with
probability 0.3 and then after that we
always pick c
so here we're in
s1 so therefore so we either move to s2
or s3 with
probability 0.5 here we've moved to s0
so then we've got to go back to s1 first
and then we perform c and we have a 50
50 choice
that we go to s2 or ss3
so that completes this select video and
in
so the next one i'll move on to
probabilistic reachability
for mdps